welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and loki's newest trailer reveals
the haunting voice of miss minutes and
loki joining the gratuitous nudity club
previously dominated by his adopted
brother and his friends
he thick that's a thick ass ball
i'm gonna break down all the new details
hidden in this footage
already confirming some theories and
raising even more interesting questions
spoiler warning in case my theories are
right but if not that's okay because
more fun to be surprised
welcome to the tom variance authority
i miss minutes and it's my job to catch
you up before you stand trial
for your crimes so settle in now
hang on just a minute all right we open
on loki getting dragged into the tva by
hunter b-15 where he is greeted by the
voice of tva mascot miss
minutes oh miss minutes and it's my job
to catch you up before you stand trial
for your crime now we don't know for
certain who this voice actress is but it
sounds a lot like tara strong who's
voiced everyone from harley quinn in the
games to raven and teen titans to
assorted characters in rick and morty
which is how we got to interview her
last year on ricksplain she's super
funny super nice
and i gotta give myself a point here for
my first and maybe only accurate
prediction for loki
since before we heard miss minute's
voice i did bring up tara strong as a
possible option on last week's episode
of inside marvel
someone from the rick and morty universe
you know could be really fun
sarah chalky or tara strong we
interviewed her for
explained like this kind of seems like a
character she's like oh man you
interviewed tara strong i'm so jealous
but unlike the scoopers i'm gonna say
this lucky call doesn't make my
predictions any more reliable going
forward so don't hold me to this [ __ ] so
miss minutes is a seemingly cute but
actually dark and terrifying animated
mascot for the tva
looks like something out of rick and
morty like mr meeseeks or mr poopy
butthole or maybe even that unsettling
clock from the don't hug me i'm scared
whatever the [ __ ] that thing's supposed
to be but i love how strong plays the
character with a southern accent kind of
like mr dna
in jurassic park mr d where did you come
from from your blood
just one drop of your blood contains
billions of strands of dna
then loki's brought before this retro
robot it begins with an upset charlie
brown face says
loki is still clothed but then after
de-clothing him his face switches to a
smile yeah i'd bet you'd be smiling with
that view
and i like how this robot's device
erases loki's clothes
with a wave of a laser wand looking like
the hand of the clock
moving counterclockwise as if rewinding
his clothes out of existence
kind of like when that time stone was
used to rewind time in doctor strange in
infinity war it operated on this same
directional logic
from here loki drops into another
chamber that we actually saw in the
december trailer now wearing the tba
detainee jumpsuit so perhaps this
gateway is a kind of scanner to verify
identity or maybe confiscate any hidden
weapons
and that's how he loses his daggers and
then part of this
booking process leads located to the
transcript room that we've seen if you
think about it each step forces loki to
suddenly drop which must be especially
aggravating since we know he hated it
when doctor strange made him fall in a
free fall portal
seemingly without end
i have been falling for 30 minutes
and we'll get you in front of a judge in
no time
[Music]
who actually believes is crasser i'm
going to see your ticket no
[Music]
thanks for visiting the tva don't
hesitate to let us know how we're doing
and then loki appears another tva
checkpoint the one with the posters we
pointed out before one
showing miss minutes like curb stomping
another saying behave or you'll get your
clock cleaned and now
loki sees what that actually means the
other detainee the one played by
comedian josh fadom
gets erased from existence his clock
figuratively cleaned back to zero and
yeah
it does remind me a lot of the way the
grand master pardoned carlo for
life on sakhar and thor ragnarok and
then on the screens the black and white
version of the tva logo
appears with its slogan for all time
always
what do you want from me you put
our timeline in chaos
i want you to help us fix it now another
new shot shows the tva
wide layout except the foggy white
background we've seen in other shots now
appears
dark so why the lights out at the tva is
it under lockdown because the detainee
loki escaped and is on the loose or is
this all
contained in the eye of a giant
celestial who just blinked i wasn't
serious about that theory but
now i kind of want it to be the case
let's just say i'm real
furious about it but uh before i
continue thanks to bang energy for
sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugars and zero
artificial colors
each 16 ounce can contains 300
milligrams of caffeine
coq10 and bcaas i'm sipping on pina
colada
that nice tropical flavor that just
takes you to your happy
place but gives you the energy to fight
off any unwelcome tourist dude showing
too much skin put your shirt on
i typically pop up in a bang when i need
to pick me up in the morning or when i
need to plow through a long video and
want my mind to be alert
check out bang on instagram get 10 off
your order at bangenergy.com when you
use the code new rockstars 10. there you
can buy a variety pack of bang energy or
grab a 12 pack of citrus twist
bankster berry or the new delish
strawberry kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 to receive
ten percent off your bang energy order
that's code new york starts 10 for 10
off
then loki stands in the tva bullpen the
one with a monitor showing the timeline
it looks like he's carrying something
blue in his hand at first i thought it
was a tesseract but as a detainee i
thought they would let him carry it
around
maybe they deactivated it or like
prevented loki from using it somehow or
maybe extracted the space stone as part
of a demonstration of loki of how
the removal of an infinity stone from
its historical path
creates this branch timeline chaos
because that's what loki did and that's
why the tva blamed him for putting their
timeline into the chaos and not the
avengers
who yes did perform way more time
meddling but going by the ancient one's
explanation
loki removed an infinity stone from
where it was supposed to be in history
whereas cap ended up putting all those
stones back
loki was the one loose in there then
another improv comedian cameo here
eugene cordero playing a tva employee
this guy also showed up in a star wars
universe in the first season the
mandalorian now that mysterious floating
chunk of rock shown in the last trailer
reappears here but that horizontal
stream
is actually curving around the rock and
the stream brights up going from duller
to brighter
i don't know maybe this rock is
someplace detached from the stream of
time or someplace siphoning chronal
energy
from that time stream i honestly have no
idea this just looks
cool what could possibly go wrong
trusting loki is not a good idea
do i get a weapon gear up ah don't those
absolutely not
and then look at sword fights with a few
uniformed officers
with those shoulder loops they're
definitely dressed differently than the
other tva cops we've seen this gloomy
stair location looks similar to the
castle doors that loki approaches seen
in last month's trailer
here loki could be fighting the royal
guards of a king version of himself
one of his variant targets and lastly
here in the locker room
mobius hand loki is daggers before
hunter b-15 snatches him away
pretty surprisingly that mobius would be
so trusting maybe he's normally a desk
guy and this is actually his first field
mission
well get ready for our loki coverage
including episodes of inside marvel
moving to wednesdays on june 9th
and naturally easter egg breakdowns
thereafter by subscribing to new
rockstars and check out our merch
options at nurexor's merch.com follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you